all right all right all right
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message today is tuesday
october 26
2021 and today
is a day
that will live in infamy forever
if you are a big tech oligarch
because
most of you have probably heard the news
already
we've got some fantastic information to
share which is that rumble
rumble video rumble.com which we are
streaming on right now including youtube
and including blaze tv
has acquired
my tech company locals.com this is a
massive
massive shift in
the social media ecosystem and i'm not
just saying it because i started locals
the real resistance
not the fake resistance that the other
guys have been running with this fake
resistance where they've got the media
they've got big tech they've got all the
institutions and
they're also the resistance no
the real resistance the real
people that are fighting for free speech
online fighting for our ability to share
ideas
fighting to have technological answers
as big tech censors us and d boosts us
and shadow bans us and everything else
that they're doing as i always say to
you guys it's not the stuff that i know
that they're doing i'm worried about
it's always the stuff that i don't know
that they're doing that i'm really
worried about well today is a great day
we have decided
to sell locals to rumble rumble is run
by a spectacular
group of people i'll tell you all the
history of all of this i'm going to take
your questions by the way if you want to
join us right now at
reubenreport.locals.com
you can submit questions i'll try to get
to as many as possible i'm going to be
as transparent and open as humanly
possible about the deal about my
relationship with rumble going forward
how we're going to structure this and
how the companies will remain separate
but still be able to share resources and
why we're so mission aligned and all of
that
but rumble's really run by some
spectacular people chris who runs
rumble uh well assaf who is my business
partner in locals about four or five
months ago we went to miami to sit down
with him for dinner just to talk about
having a partnership just to be like hey
could we you know do a few different
things together there you know there's
obviously some interesting touch points
here and you know maybe there's a bigger
opportunity down down the line we
literally sat down for dinner and before
the wine bottle was even uncorked
chris said hey
we want to we want to buy you guys we
want to acquire you guys
and for the last five months roughly
it's even more than that i think this
started probably in may or so uh we've
been trying to tie all of that together
and i can tell you as someone that
didn't intend on starting a tech company
uh that there's a whole lot of stuff
involved not only in building a tech
company but selling a tech company and i
couldn't be prouder of what we've done
here you know i always knew
from when we when we started locals
that this was just a piece
of the bigger puzzle right like there
were going to have to be so many
interesting new innovative companies
that we're going to have to come and
have technological answers and we're
going to have to deal with all of the
free speech issues and the censorship
issues honestly and forthrightly and all
of those things and i also knew that it
was just going to keep getting worse you
know when i started this company which
was three years ago it was basically
three years ago
in december december 2018 and i'll tell
you why i started it for those of you
that that may not remember or weren't on
board this crazy adventure at the time
uh but when i started i knew that we
were just going to build
a part of what the solution was going to
be and that eventually we would partner
up with other people who are doing cool
things
and that's exactly where we are at today
which is why i am so thrilled uh to
announce that we are partnering up and
have been acquired by rumble it's not
only chris over there who's run an
incredible team and he's been running
this company for years sort of under the
radar building an incredible truly an
incredible infrastructure that is going
to
replace amazon aws you know i know
everybody's worried about well dave what
about parlor that was the big thing that
i heard over the last year you know
you've done so many interesting things
with locals and you got live video
streaming and the unmanipulated uh news
feed and we're liking and we can live
chat and all of that stuff but what
about the servers what about the servers
well we did some things on the back end
that are a little too insider baseball
to get into but rumble has truly built
the infrastructure for the what i would
say is the parallel ecosystem that we
are going to build we are going to build
a parallel
ecosystem outside of big tech where
there will be video there will be audio
there will be the ability for you guys
to communicate back and forth we're
going to have subscription models we're
going there will be ads you know they're
everything everything that exists we're
going to replicate but do it right and
do it better and do it not to manipulate
you or to sell your data or to decide
what you can and can't say right that's
not the business that i'm in it's not
the business that i want to be in you if
you don't break the laws of the united
states you're basically okay you know if
you break the united states you got a
bigger problem than dave rubin all right
so that that's our basic mission but not
only has chris built some incredible
tech here uh but you know dan bongino
who i truly hold in like the highest
possible regard as one of the people
involved in in this political
sort of disaster that we're all in right
we're all in this like political
meltdown right now and there are a
couple people who are not only talking
about the right ideas to get out of it
but doing the right things actually
building the right things so dan is a
part of rumble dan and i will be working
together to be the public voices of
rumble and of locals as we
go down the line and and try to solve
all of the problems that the internet
has right now whether it's payment
processors whether it's censorship etc
etc so i'm thrilled to be doing that a
couple things before i get into some of
the nitty gritty in the history and as i
said uh you can submit as many questions
as you want you can ask me as personal
stuff uh specifics on the deal etc at
reubenreport.locals.com
and i already did a locals exclusive
live stream this morning so for those of
you that watch that i know some of this
will be a little bit repetitive but i
want to get as much information out as
possible i also want to be as
transparent as possible you know that
was one of the big things
that when we sat down with chris and we
sat down with dan it's like we've all
seen the mistakes of 20 years of the
internet
and i'm not calling all of these guys
evil you know what i mean like that's
one of the things i try when i talk
about zuckerberg or jack
dorsey from twitter and all of these
guys it's like i think they all got into
something that they didn't know what the
hell they were getting into and then i
think these things became just too big
and unmanageable and did they make some
bad decisions was there probably some
nefarious activity is there a lot of
wokeness involved that allows them to do
all sorts of bad things and do they
maybe not even know all of the bad
things that their companies are doing
yes that is all true
but now it's like we can learn from
their mistakes that's the beautiful
thing right now we can learn from the
mistakes of 20 years of giant companies
that made you the product we do not want
you to be the product at rumble or at
locals and and that is going to be a key
to everything we're doing so when when
i've sat down with assaf who as i said
was the architect of locals and when we
sat down with chris who started rumbling
we sat down with bon gino it's like
we're gonna do everything we can to sort
of build not only a parallel ecosystem
but a mature ecosystem you know what do
i say all the time it's like build new
things
build new things and nobody does it
every everyone just complains but there
were a couple people out there building
new things and that's exactly why we
thought that this was the right deal uh
guys i got one ad for you before i get
into all of the uh the specifics and if
there was ever a day that dave rubin is
gonna drink a nice bottle of wine today
is the day i assure you i've got some
malbec right here are you looking
forward to a big thanksgiving meal a big
thanksgiving meal needs a heftier wine
and this year especially i think we all
deserve something with bold flavor and
complex personality imagine offering
your family and friends a glass of wine
that comes directly from the highest
vineyards in the entire world that's six
thousand to nine thousand feet any
higher and the grapes wouldn't be able
to survive what does it all mean for the
wine a flavor unlike any wine you've
ever tasted blackberry leather smoke and
some dark cherry this stuff packs a
punch my friends over at
freethinkerwine.com are bringing these
rare wines to americans for the holidays
the best part they've cut out the
middleman so you won't deal with any big
industry markup while dave and i love to
host these wines also make great gifts
if you're attending a dinner party as a
guest and if you're curious about the
pairing malbecs go particularly well
with dark turkey meat spices like sage
and pepper and sauces like creamy
mushroom i'm getting hungry already
visit freethinkerwine.com and you'll get
top quality extreme altitude wine for
about half the price perfect for your
thanksgiving meal with the family no
need for a promo code just visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com
and now back to me okay so obviously a
ton to get to here so as i said we've
we've been working on this deal for
about five months
let me tell you also that we had other
deals we had people offer us all cash to
buy the company there's obviously been a
lot going on here
one of the interesting things just sort
of generally about what's happened sort
of in the zeitgeist in the last year is
when the events of january 6th happened
and then parlor was blown up
which actually was much more of a threat
in my opinion to free speech the the
destruction of parlor
rather than the silliness that happened
for the most part on the sixth itself at
the capitol
which of course is not to deny that
anything bad happened and the people
that broke the law should be dealt with
and all of that stuff okay but the
greater threat to american values and
free speech and your ability to speak
your mind was that amazon blew up the
competition all of big tech they said
we're gonna destroy parlor parlor's got
23 million users we don't like them this
is the perfect excuse now ironically it
turned out that more people had
coordinated the events of january 6th on
facebook than on parlor but you know
this is sort of a mafia game they're not
gonna blow themselves up so they blew up
parlor what that then caused was the
average person to go well okay it
doesn't matter what i think politically
but just blowing up websites
that that doesn't seem very safe that
doesn't seem good for anybody that might
have a unique point of view or might
just want to speak freely or you know
might just you know occasionally say
something that's not totally politically
correct um and what that allowed was a
sort of a movement where suddenly people
who were not looking to invest in things
suddenly decided to invest in things it
really helped our growth on the local
side but really as i said before about
rumble it's like they are ensuring they
have built the infrastructure it's built
already this is not like oh they're
going to build this stuff in five years
they are building the new infrastructure
and and have built a new infrastructure
so that your websites will stay online
so that if you say that you're against
masked mandates you don't have to worry
that amazon's going to blow up your
server so that if you say that uh you
know let's say you like this guy brandon
you know there's some guy brandon in
your town and he's walking by and you're
like let's go brandon well you know that
your website's not going to get blown
out blown apart so there were many
reasons that we wanted to come together
on this front and i want to just back up
a little bit to
december of 2018 which is basically
three years ago when i when i first sort
of got the idea for locals
you know i was on tour with jordan
peterson at the time we were at the tail
end of the tour we had done about 100
stops we had about 10 or 15 shows to go
mostly in australia which unfortunately
it doesn't look like any freedom loving
person is going to australia anytime
soon
little did we know that was going to
happen three years later but it was
december of uh 2018 and i was on patreon
at the time that's where i was doing the
crowdsourcing the subscription model for
my show we were doing quite well on
there i was one of the first if not the
first political guy on there and you
know it was mostly like gamers and that
sort of thing but i had gone independent
i had left you know i had started the
young turks i had eventually moved over
to aura tv i left the networks i wanted
to go independent i wanted to build my
own home studio and all of these things
and i was on patreon we were doing well
i had built a company i had several
employees we were making like 30 grand a
month it was great everything was good
and then one day in december of 2018 a
guy that i'm sure many of you are
familiar with by the name of sargon of
akkad uh carl benjamin over in the uk uh
he was kicked off patreon out of nowhere
i was on the road with jordan peterson
at the time when i saw it i was i
remember i was doing cardio in the hotel
and i saw it and i could not believe it
and what basically had happened was that
carl had said the n-word
but not on his youtube channel nor on
his patreon he had said it on someone
else's channel and he also did not say
it to be racist he said it because he
was mocking the very racist people who
use words like that patreon did not care
they did not send him any warning they
just blew up his patreon channel which
was his main source of income they
didn't say oh can you clarify this or oh
you didn't do this on your youtube
channel or your patreon you did it
basically in the privacy of your own
life you did on somebody else's channel
just talking or that it wasn't racist in
the first place anyway to to jordan and
i that was such a drastic drastic
escalation
of what had happened of what was going
on with big tech we all knew about
shadow bands and that at times you know
your tweets just aren't seen or we had
all known about
videos not going out to youtube when you
put up a live stream or you put up new
videos or subscribers dropping out of
nowhere or every day i would wake up and
people would be emailing me dave i don't
see your videos like we had known all of
that stuff right and it was unfolding in
front of our eyes and sometimes you know
when all of these weird things are
happening and they're de-boosting things
and you know they say that they're
unmanipulating search results as they
manipulate them all of this crazy stuff
it's like it's hard to keep up with it
you sort of feel like a conspiracy
theorist it's like a lot to deal with at
once anyway this one was such a direct
assault on freedom of speech because it
wasn't just that he didn't say the word
to be racist he didn't even do it on
patreon and he didn't even do it on
youtube that patreon was funding right
so we immediately agreed that we were
going to leave patreon we didn't know
exactly how we were going to do it as i
it was about 90 percent of my company's
revenue at the time and i went to my
brother-in-law assaf who's a product guy
and i said look i need you to build me a
subscription page so that i can get off
patreon jordan and i decided to leave
patreon then sam harris left patreon a
couple other big people did and i
believe it was on january 15 2019 if i'm
not mistaken that i officially
left patreon
and we launched what was literally just
one page it was just a page on
reubenreport.com just saying you could
subscribe
just subscribe to
dave rubin and you know throw in a
couple bucks i think the minimum at that
time was three dollars throw in a couple
bucks and you you will help dave not be
so beholden to big tech well once we did
that and overnight i think our revenue
jumped by about 30 because people
respect when you stand up for the right
things we thought well hold on now we
maybe have something here if we can
solve some of my problems as a creator
we can solve all sorts of problems for
all sorts of people not just political
people or not just people that i agree
with but for gamers and on boxers and
all of the other people who are doing
all the weird things online like maybe
we can solve a lot of their problems as
well
and that really was
where uh the beginnings of locals began
and then i did a live stream saying that
you know we were thinking about building
something and if you want to understand
really how cool this is how this
adventure that i've been on has just
been
absolutely extraordinary i did a live
stream just saying you know we we
started we didn't even have a company
yet actually i don't even think we even
had an llc yet but i said you know we're
starting something here we think there's
an opportunity to build video for people
and audio and have a home that's yours
and you know build a slick app so you
can get push notifications and
eventually we'll have live stream all
this stuff and i'm just like babbling on
a lot a two-hour live stream and i said
you know boy if i if i knew some
billionaires right now uh that would be
helpful if i knew some people that could
invest in this sort of thing that could
be helpful
and uh a guy by the name of andrew sent
me an email i saw an email from a guy
named andrew hey you're looking for a
billionaire and uh and andrew showed up
and and wrote the first check for uh
locals and that that began the process
and then after that as we raised funds
over the last couple years uh a couple
people uh most notably warren and mark
shout out to you guys as well as andrew
and a few others that were just viewers
of mine that were just
people who enjoyed what i did who liked
the things that i was talking about also
became investors and i think this is
going to work out pretty well for you
guys so i think it's pretty fantastic
and then along the way
very cool things kept happening back in
last december
i was in miami with a sophomore we're
sitting at a table with investors and
and i should tell you guys that we had
gone to silicon valley like two and a
half years ago before before it had
completely melted down in san francisco
and everybody has now escaped and left
but we had gone to to raise funds and we
went into every office like name a vc
firm we went into every single office
great pitches our docs were great you
know i'm a pretty decent talker we knew
what we were talking about
and basically everybody
turned us down not because anyone had a
problem with the mission not because
anyone had a problem with the tech that
we built not because anyone had a
problem with us but basically every
single person on the dl very few would
put it in an email would say you know
this is great and we do kind of need
this and yeah youtube's kind of evil and
twitter is horrible and all that but you
know this is sort of conservative it
seems like you know you're conservative
dave you're sort of scary and the the
creators they seem to lean a little
right and that that could be dangerous
for us i cannot tell you how many times
we heard that but we just kept going we
just kept going and going and building
and not taking no for an answer and the
company kept growing and our growth was
spectacular and our feature set kept
growing and and more and more good kept
happening and by the way as we were
doing that that's exactly what rumble
was doing on their side so these things
were just kind of moving up together at
the same time and that's a that's a
pretty beautiful thing so i want to be
clear about a couple things here that
are that's very important so yes
locals is being 100 or has been 100
acquired by rumble uh it was a stock
deal so i'm not walking out with the
whole boatload of cash uh but i believe
in this company i believe that there's
huge opportunity in the future and i
think this is the right decision not
only for me and for the for my family
but for the growth of what we are trying
to do to actually build something that
will fight against big tech that being
said locals will continue to basically
run independently although it will be
part of rumble assaf will continue to
run locals we are here for creators we
want to be the platform for creators to
be completely independent to own their
data to own their content to be able to
communicate directly with their audience
if you're watching this and you're on
patreon get on locals get on locals we
have a much better product a slick app
with live streaming and live chat and
push notifications and all of those
things so
what this does though is allow us to
have way more resources it allows us to
have the awesome technological underside
that rumble is providing and it allows
us to further that ecosystem so you can
sort of think about it
roughly like in the way that facebook
bought instagram now they're obviously
two separate brands but they work
together in all sorts of ways you may
not like exactly how they work together
but meaning that they're separate
companies but obviously they're working
together they're sharing all sorts of
resources and everything else that
that's the way we plan on doing this uh
i am sticking around by the way so i
want to be a hundred percent clear on
that as well
i could have
done a deal here and there was some talk
about i could have done a deal where i
would just walk that i would basically
just sell the company for stock and i'd
walk and hopefully one day the stock
does great and you know i've saved
myself a lot of meetings and everything
else because in the last three years i
would say believe it or not
probably more than half of my work day
has been spent on local stuff
more than even doing the reuben report i
know that may sound almost impossible
but the amount of investor meetings the
amount of onboarding of creators the
amount of talking to lawyers about
policy and everything else that i've
done that that's sort of how my life's
been for the last couple years i've
actually loved every second of it i
didn't know i was going to love it i
didn't intend on becoming a tech guy
but because it's so closely associated
with everything that i talk about here
um it just it felt great um but in any
event i could have just walked right
like today's announcement could be you
know we sold it and uh you know rumble's
taking over and the soft's gonna go get
a new job and you know i'm out i did
what i could but that's not what we
wanted to do we wanted to not only
continue to build locals and as i said
make it the premier place for creators
online you should not be on patreon if
you're on there you're just on another
big tech thing which has almost no
feature set by the way all they're doing
is is taking care of your monthly
subscriptions like let us do it and
we'll give you a whole bunch more okay
that's my sales pitch on that um but i
am sticking around i am going to be a
salaried employee of
rumble to be very clear in the first two
years with locals i didn't take a dime i
actually put money in and put a lot of
time in obviously this last year i took
a very nominal salary but i will be a
salaried employee i'm sticking around i
alongside dan bongino want to be the the
public people that are fighting for the
right ideas related to freedom of speech
online we will do our best and i really
mean this we will do our best to be as
transparent as we can about our policies
and what we're doing you know i say this
all the time but it's like if you're on
gmail most of us have a gmail account
imagine you just had a problem with
gmail you couldn't get in you're locked
out anything just something's not
working it doesn't seem like your emails
are moving i don't know whatever it's
like there's nobody on the phone to talk
to is there there's nobody to get
through over there and it's like we want
to build a much better company if you
had a problem with twitter who you gonna
call right right it's like
you'd have a better chance to call the
ghostbusters honestly than getting in
touch with anyone at twitter um so we
want to be the people dan and i that are
leading the fight you know i've said for
so long i like people that build things
i got sick i really got sick of just
talking about problems you can you can
watch my old shows and i'm sure some of
you remember this where we'd be talking
about free speech we'd be talking about
big tech and i'd have great thoughtful
people on and you could feel the
frustration it was like well no
nothing's getting better nothing's
getting better why don't we build this
um
and just for the record there's several
uh people that were former guests on the
room report i did offer pieces of locals
if they would get involved and and work
with us and
a lot of people are not looking very
bright today um
so but it's all good it's really it's
all good i'm i'm super excited so okay
so let me let me take a couple questions
there are obviously uh a few other
things that i want to hit on oh i
started telling you just real quick i
started telling you about uh this
meeting back in december so in december
i'm sitting around this table in miami
with a bunch of investors and we're
trying to raise money for locals
and i did something that i don't know
that any investor in the history of tech
has ever done we're sitting at this
table i post in my locals community i
say hey guys uh i'm at an investor
dinner here in miami could you guys just
comment on why you like locals be as
brutally honest as you want whatever you
want to say go ahead i posted that now
people get push notifications on their
phone so several hundred people started
commenting i did not even look i swear
to you i did not even look at the phone
i just handed my phone around the table
and got all these investors to look at
the comments and we walked out of there
with investors okay so when i say that
you guys built this with us i actually
mean that you guys were a key piece of
us building this and that's what's so
cool not only do we have
viewers and fans that heard me through
the pipes man you heard me you heard the
message and you said i want to get in on
that oh and marcus i forgot about marcus
who is also a key part of this as long
as i'm talking about fans and viewers
that were investors like people who have
met in real life and broken bread with
who were like yeah dave i think you're
doing something decent how can i help um
so
you guys did it i i handed that phone
around the table people were like holy
cow this is incredible people i was just
watching them scrolling and scrolling
this amazing and all my push
notifications you guys are getting
messed up there's no hate on here
it's pretty awesome pretty awesome so
i'm so proud of what we've built and i
truly mean we when i say that so let me
get to some uh some questions then i'll
share a couple other thoughts and as i
said if you're if you're in the reuben
report.locals.com
chat right now which of course you can
get on ios app or on android or if
you're on desktop
i'm more than happy to answer anything
about this whatever you got throw it at
me i'm just looking at the screen and
they're gonna throw me some questions uh
because says couldn't be more pumped on
the news for you and everyone involved
absolutely love this app and rumble is
incredible hell of a combo i appreciate
it well we're mission aligned right like
that's that's the key thing here we were
not i'm telling you we had cash offers
to buy the company i could have just
walked with a lot of cash
we had other sort of interesting offers
um but we wanted to further the mission
like
what's the point of me talking all day
about politics and free speech and all
of this stuff
if
we were to sell to a company that was
just going to disassemble it or just
take you know basically fleece it for
parts or whatever it's like i know for a
fact
that locals is stronger today and we
will i'm telling you if you work at
patreon you may want to send us a resume
because we're coming for you and if you
work at youtube you may want to send
rumble a resume because we're coming for
you and we will this is completely
consistent with everything else i say in
general don't expect the government to
save you anymore okay they're not going
to save you yeah there's some good
governors desantis in florida and i'll
mention something about florida in just
a
sec
there are a couple good people who are
fighting for the right ideas but don't
think the people above you are gonna
save you above you right um
you can save yourself and how do you do
that you build new products build new
institutions build new everything that's
exactly what we're doing here and and i
know i know if we just have the people
behind us like this is this is a
movement for the people it truly is and
and that's what we're going to keep
building and and everything that we've
done i mean we beta tested this with my
with my fans like everything that we've
done is because of you guys uh
liberalsunite says will you still have a
youtube presence yes absolutely hey
youtube susan i'm gonna leverage the
hell out of youtube to drive traffic to
rumble and to blaze tv and i want to be
very clear about something i love the
guys at blaze tv this in no way is in
conflict with anything at the blaze tv i
love i love tyler i love gaston
everybody is great we're going to keep
working together i think there could be
huge opportunities on that front as well
as the whole ecosystem comes together
but yeah i intend to intend on staying
on youtube for now
because youtube is still the place for
discovery right i still want to bring in
new people so that i can
talk about the things that i care about
hopefully enlighten people and continue
to further the the ideological mission
that i'm working on over here
but of course i want to drive more
viewers to rumble and i want more uh
subscribers to join us over at
locals.com and you know every rumble
creator is going to have immediate
access to a local's community that's how
they'll be able to fund what they're
doing
they're thinking about all sorts of
interesting stuff i think chris has been
teasing this out i think i'm not going
to get any trouble for this one but i
mean rumble's been thinking about doing
100 of ad revenue to the creators like
we're really trying to rethink
the entire thing uh backup never says
are you losing control of this platform
what's to stop rumble from selling to
the dark side all right great question
and i appreciate the honesty and the and
the directness so am i losing control of
this platform so me dave will no longer
be in control of
locals in the most technical sense of
that assaf who built this with me is the
ceo of locals he remains the ceo of
locals not only is he my brother-in-law
but i know the guy pretty well and he is
completely mission aligned uh you know
we have all sorts of people on locals
right now who disagree with me
politically there are plenty of people
on locals who don't like dave rubin at
all okay
there are plenty of people no doubt on
rumble who don't like me that's okay we
are not in this to censor people if you
are on rumble or you are on locals and
you are threatening to murder somebody
or planning a terrorist attack law
enforcement is going to deal with you
but beyond that we are not here to
police speech if you disagree with
everything that i say if you
are a socialist
bernie loving npc
genderless
unicorn you are welcome on rumble well
i'll even write you a note
welcome from dave rubin that would be
we'd be happy to have you but if you
break the law of the united states you
know you try to kill somebody you got a
bigger problem than us so we are going
to deal with the speech issues as
cleanly and clearly as possible
and by the way you know on the local
side of this once you have a couple uh
dollar
buy-in on the subscription side which
the minimum on locals is three dollars
to start a community mine is five
dollars i think scott adams is seven
dollars we have some people that charge
fifteen dollars a month once you do that
99.9 of the bad behavior is gone because
because once people put a little skin in
the game once they say hey this thing
has some value to me their behavior gets
better so there are all sorts of
political opinions that are happening in
the reuben report community and i like
when people disagree with me or i see
people in the comments section going
back and forth but somehow we've managed
to do it without the trolls without the
bots without the endless hate we're
actually building something better we
really are nuclear patrick says do you
think locals and trump's forthcoming
platform will be able to both co-exist
and prosper yes absolutely you know when
you're building new institutions you've
got to build a lot of institutions you
have to build cultural institutions
educational institutions i think we're
going to need some new political
institutions unfortunately technological
institutions everything else so i don't
have the full scope of exactly what
trump is doing although i do know that
you know him doing this spac to ipo
thing a couple days ago and then the
exploding
valuation of this thing is just
incredible and he'll be able to buy all
sorts of companies and and i think this
thing is much different than from the
desk of donald trump like he's really on
to something real this time um i think
this offers huge opportunity huge as
donald was a huge opportunity for all of
us like i love competition it's not just
something i say it's like man if if
trump starts building something and then
they've got amazing programming and
amazing tech and all that it's like i
have no doubt i'm going to end up on a
zoom call with chris and asaph and dan
and we're going to go boy you know
they're doing some good stuff over there
should we talk to those guys can we work
together can we buy them can they buy us
like can we figure out all the pieces
here to just continue
to get the off-ramp from big tech
in in a sensible fashion that that's
really that's it uh lin
1966 says how will this affect my
subscription on locals it will not
affect it at all locals will continue to
operate as is as i said we're going to
have more resources now so i think
there's things that we're going to be
able to build more quickly than we have
i think we've done a pretty great job
you know every time i promised something
we did it first live text chat live
video chat etc etc
but we will have plenty of resources now
to build things faster use the rumble
infrastructure to secure all of our
properties but nothing will change on
the local side in that regard i will say
that we are working on the locals bundle
i know you guys have been asking us for
this for about a year and it's something
that we've we know we have to do at some
point and what i mean by bundle is let's
say you like dave rubin you like scott
adams you like tulsi gabbard you like uh
bridgette fedezee and michael malus well
if you're paying five bucks for all of
those people that adds up very quickly
so we're trying to figure out a bundle
package it's obviously very complex to
do because if you have a whole bunch of
different creators who who maybe
somebody's bigger than somebody else do
they get a higher cut we have a couple
models for we're working on it
to be totally transparent we were a
little sidetracked with dealing with a
lot of lawyers
over the last couple months
but yes we do plan on getting back to
that uh amy b says are you going to do
an orlando meetup this weekend at the
national conservatism conference yes
there will be a locals booth so locals
is sponsoring it in you know it's really
in conjunction with rumble at this point
we are sponsoring the event i'm going to
do tons of interviews and there's they
have an incredible speaker line up there
peter thiel jd vance marco rubio ted
cruz chris ruffo ayan herciali
uh there's just like give me a give me a
couple other names that are that are
going to be there so i'm going to be
interviewing people i will be there the
entire time i'm speaking on november 2nd
i'm closing the the event uh teal
speaking on the 31st uh but i will be
there the entire time we'll figure out a
meet-up and hopefully i can do a meet-up
uh you know get some drinks with you
with you fine people in miami oh glenn
lowry will be there uh sora bamari josh
hawley it's a reuben report reunion
basically uh kate in arizona any chance
of rumble moving to miami with locals oh
i'm glad you asked this question because
you know i just did the the locals
exclusive live stream this morning and
one thing that kept coming up was that a
lot of people were concerned that rumble
uh
as it stands so far is a canadian
company and obviously canada has not
been friendly on the free speech front
that is absolutely true and it's a great
question i'm glad so many people asked
so i don't want to say anything specific
but i've heard a rumor
who told me this rumor was it you was it
you as you somebody around here told me
a rumor that rumble might be moving to
the sunshine state
i've said too much um so i don't think
you're gonna have to worry about that
sort of thing
uh florida is the sunshine state by the
way you don't have to google it there's
a lot of sun it's very sun sunny humid
uh so locals is already in miami um i
sense that perhaps if these rumors you
know if you hear something online it's
got to be true so i would imagine that
it is possible that rumble's uh gonna
head down there and uh we shall see what
happens but you don't
the the the real answer on that joking
aside is you do not have to worry about
any of the ridiculous the really
ridiculous and draconian uh laws that
canada has around free speech and
they're really coming for the internet
they're coming for the creators you
don't have to worry about that you
really don't
john says so when are you finally going
to leave california
i am going to florida next week um for
this event that i just mentioned and
then i am staying for
some days after so you can read into
that what you will you know i mean i
don't want to start a rumor
you know how these rumors go when
they're on the computer they start
spreading like wildfire next thing you
know cnn's calling you a misinformation
uh assassin
gotta watch out for that
um
i think that's i think that's most of it
i think that's most of it i i do want to
say uh
just not only i think i started with
this and i i said it in the
live stream earlier but i'm like
incredibly humbled today and you know i
didn't intend on doing any of this
and because i just say what i think for
a living
people
seem to gravitate to that and then as i
said then suddenly when i had a project
people were like i'd like to put money
towards that project i'd like to help
promote that project we met coders who
were like i'd like to work for free we
always make sure we pay people because i
don't want people to work for free i
believe work has value
and and people should get paid for their
work um
but you know we we built a company that
we we moved down to a state that i think
is doing things right in a city that i
think is doing things right if you
haven't seen my interview with miami may
or suarez you should check it out like
they're really building the new silicon
valley there and i really do believe
this guys um we can win this thing you
know david beat goliath and the big tech
situation i know it feels like goliath
it feels like they own all of us they
could destroy all of us everyone's
feeling in every part of their life
right now i think everyone is sort of
feeling ah
something's not right with the world the
media lies to us big tech manipulates us
they want to inject my children with
things they tell us masks don't work
because you touch your face more and
then they tell us to double mess like
everything
is sort of like this cascade of [ __ ]
right now and i i
do what i do to help clean it up and the
world in that regard has been pretty
good to me yeah there's a couple people
that don't like me it's true
and you know nobody's perfect
but as i've built this thing
i was able to take all of the things
that i've learned all of the the ideas
you know sitting down with a great
economist like thomas soule a legend
sitting down with thomas not only did it
change my feeling on economics
right but it also then was like all
right maybe i should start a business
maybe i should put some of this stuff
into practice
and that's exactly what we did so every
time a door closed at you know in
silicon valley and when i mentioned like
you know going in and just people you
know companies that had billions of
dollars that could have just thrown you
know blown us out through the roof
immediately when they said no for all
the wrong reasons and you and you know
who the cowards are like i know i got a
mental list now of like who the cowards
are and who the brave people are and
it's like i want to work with brave
people
i want to work with people who are who
have a mission who want to accomplish
something but not just anything right
like like the lefties and the people who
are here to
silence us they're on a mission that's
not the mission i want to be on i want
to be on a mission with a team of people
who want to free us who want you to live
how you see fit who want to be proud of
this great country
and and all of the freedoms that it has
brought all of us i know that's what
we're doing here with the rumble team
like i'm telling you i know these guys
now we've had enough discussions about
this stuff um we would not have sold
otherwise i did not need to do this i
did not i enjoy the work okay
this came to us
and and i think the best is yet to come
i really do
and and all of us for you guys that are
part of this it's like you know i did a
video a couple years ago about two years
ago called bravery deficit for prageru
and it's like if right now if you're
feeling good after watching this right
if you're like man there's some good
stuff happening it's like figure out how
to incorporate that into your life
whether that's you know somebody at work
saying something to you and you actually
saying something back instead of not
saying it uh whatever that means to you
if you're if you're getting a you know
a diversity inclusion and equity memo at
your office turning it around and saying
to the hr guy you know this is racist
i'm not a racist and i don't i don't
believe in this you know they can't fire
all of us they can't silence all of us
they can't they can't just crush all of
us and now they really can't because we
are going to have technological answers
to that
so
on this tuesday i thank you guys for
watching and uh as i have many many
times said to my crew in this room and
as i have many times said to the locals
team uh we're just right back at the
beginning again because now it's like on
one hand this morning like when i saw
that the press release run out i was
like all right it's done it's free it's
out there in the world there was this
like sort of exhale but now it's like
now we got work to do so i'm ready to
work and i thank you guys for being on
this adventure with me uh we will
continue to build out
all of the right tech
while we fight for the right ideas
and i look forward to being on the
adventure with you so have a great day
everybody